[Music]
you guys ever get anything stolen from
your house yup yeah hell yeah yeah
what's the most recent thing wasn't it
your [ __ ]
[ __ ] your bike uh oh yeah that's the
most recent yeah my honda ruckus right
out of the garage it's a shared garage
so it's like it's one of those things
where it's like is it the the
maintenance people the like inside job
yeah do you think it was do you know i
don't know you heard anything about it
since nope
well you did a police report right i did
but then like they give a [ __ ]
the dude was just training a cop on how
to [ __ ] file a police report how to
not file one i saw um
it happened when i was uh
seven
my grandparents are over and everyone's
taking like their afternoon nap
and i was gonna go to the garage to um
ride a bike and when i go in the garage
i see these kids
like trying to pick my grandpa's bikes
lock and they took my bike and then so i
ran in i grabbed my grandpa and we ran
out they were able to get that lock open
somehow so they took the bikes and then
me and my grandpa were just running down
the sidewalk and then uh
that bike ended up just disappearing
because they're just running they were
running not using the bike
[Music]
hey use the bike dude that's so [ __ ]
sad yeah i was like seven is that your
first uh witness of like thievery like
just someone taking something of yours
yeah the thing is um the it was like a
like a suburb type of community
so it felt like um ever it was really
small so one of the bigger kids i was
like wait i think i've seen that kid
with some other kid before so when i
went back to the park shout out to
friendship park
um wow we i asked around and then we
found out where the kid lived and then
so he called the cops we ended up
getting the bike back which is cool wow
oh you got it back yeah we got it back
but then when we got there i remember
even being
as a kid
i felt
um because you know when you're a kid
you don't really have that much insight
but i remember even as a kid when i
arrived at that person's house
i felt bad for the kids family already
like i felt like oh these actually
weren't bad kids they their
environment's bad
like they probably have alcoholic father
or generational gangs or whatever i was
like
i was like oh [ __ ] no wonder they would
have kids like this but you still took
your bike back huh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they got you know
they got all the they gotta learn the
consequences to learn you know me if
they're young too so when i was in
eighth grade we came home one time and
uh
the door the front door was like was was
locked but then our kitchen door
it was like a screen door and was wedged
open with a slipper
and the door
was was broken into
and we found all the stuff
stolen it was like my dad's laptop was
stolen
there was a box of donuts that we had
that we bought from the store that was
sealed and it was what's up intimates i
don't know actually but it was it was
ripped open and there was a bunch of
donuts taken out and it was a fresh box
so we were like okay sentiments and go
in the bathroom
in my bathroom some dude took a [ __ ]
in the bathroom
no toilet paper did it flush just left a
[ __ ] log and then was like rifling
through a bunch of [ __ ] like the house
was a mess it's like these [ __ ]
donuts
[Music]
raspberries
he's like that's not even a donut it's a
[ __ ] sheet
[Laughter]
this guy was like he stole a bunch of
cash from my like my dad's house my
dad's room and then just stole a bunch
of like random earrings from my mom's
well they had time that's just something
he took a [ __ ] in your bed yeah
[ __ ] at my bathroom like a kid's room oh
he's like this will be hilarious [ __ ]
drop the deuce and then that was it does
it feel like uh
invasion of pride oh yeah that was the
second time that's happened too within
like three years what city was this you
know
don't say it somebody's stealing all
your donuts and taking chips in your
house
that was a that was the second time our
house got robbed wow wow
yeah yeah but the guy took her [ __ ] in
my bathroom you know
he left it he didn't flush it
second that's crazy and i was like and
my mom goes yeah you deserve this you
deserve it when i live when i live with
my dad in armani uh my car broke into
twice
one week right after the other oh
like did you have to like fix the window
right when you fix it broke again nah
that one was
completely my bad because this was like
during my raver days where i had like a
12-inch subwoofer in like my trunk right
oh yeah so like all the older homies are
like when you're like two blocks away
from your house stop bumping your [ __ ]
you know that's what they always tell
but then when you're like a kid you
don't listen to anyone even the older
homies so as i come home every single
day i'm just bumping f yeah [ __ ] loud
as [ __ ] i pull up into you know my dad's
house there's that little canopy thing i
would pull up in there and then the
first time i came out um it was like
window shattered
um
what does it call it all like my
subwoofer taken out all that stuff
and then we got it fixed i'm all right
cool but i'm still but i don't have a
subwoofer anymore i'm still bumping me
he's like a [ __ ] dumbass and then
this time i come out and my door was
just slightly ajar oh and i'm like
oh [ __ ] and i was like did i like not
took the radio no well they took uh so i
was i didn't have a cell phone time my
dad had a cell phone that was gone uh my
friend left his video camera in my trunk
that was gone i had a
yearbook because it was senior year and
i had all these people uh signing it oh
that i didn't get a chance to read they
took a yearbook dude they took my
yearbook
because they probably wanted to see it
sign it and read all the great if you
took a [ __ ] and
closed it
the saddest part is one of my favorite
donuts man the saddest part is one of my
favorite teachers in my whole life mrs
kumara um she's like one of the few
teachers that really believed in me i
remember seeing her write a whole page
in there so i couldn't wait to read that
shout out to mrs mark apple and i was
like oh [ __ ] man and uh that sucks yeah
cause those those things on my mat's
worthless to you an [ __ ] dude and
then all maybe they went to your high
school maybe they read it and it's like
you'll never make it you piece of [ __ ]
bart quan you always sat in my class
with those [ __ ] eyes
never paying real attention always in
your own world
trying to help you and then this guy's
like i can't let this little kid read
this [ __ ]
it'll [ __ ] him up forever
he'll never do jk
how's that for shout outs miss kimura
she spared you pain like alfred in the
dark knight i still liked her she's just
the best same thing video camera had
like your parents having sex on it it's
like yo dude you can't see this jack
that [ __ ] that's my friend's video
camera yeah why was your friend filming
yeah that's true so the reason i ask is
because
i know there is a reason really short
one though here's the theft that
happened in texas i believe yeah i love
rain camera footage so a lawn mower was
um stolen from a home here
and what makes this remarkable is that
before the thief took the lawnmower away
he mowed the front and
he filled up again why because he's on
meth
probably yeah yeah they deserve some
energy wait like why don't you wake up
when someone starts mowing your lawn in
the middle of the night is that it looks
like in the middle of the night mode is
long dude hey what would you do though
if you woke up and you're like are you
mowing my lawn
thank you both of front and back yard
and then he took it to mow the
neighbor's lawn nobody could hear that
and then you just take yeah like look at
him
he's still mowing that's a big lawn this
guy's tweaking dude yeah he's tweaking
for sure
was he picking up newspapers right now
what are you doing that's some
crackhead-ass [ __ ] dude or that's the
way you do steal a lawnmower so people
don't think it's suspicious the [ __ ] in
the middle of the night too that's on
though everyone's gonna hear that and
see you he's tweaking his phone well i
guess uh the people weren't home huh
yeah because there's no way they would
have been home and they [ __ ] this is
why you got to set your right or did he
not really turn it on if he's oh no it's
working yeah it's worse it could just be
pushing oh it's actually put in the
grass yeah he actually did a good job
uh so yeah
they ended up seeing him like like
running down the street with it they
chased him he was trying to drag it got
caught
a lot more went back to the house
probably the weirdest theft that is the
[ __ ] weirdest
that's some crack behavior dude yeah it
is or maybe that's his own way of
justifying the theft it's like if i do
some good deeds one last lawn
[Laughter]
well
his lawn would look nice until he has to
replace it or it's like why'd you steal
my lawnmower it's like dude you didn't
even need to cut your grass
you don't need it i mean that's a good
way to see if it's a lawnmower worth
stealing is you just do a test drive
or he goes or he goes look i'm gonna i'm
gonna mow the lawn
and then by the time you have to mow it
again i'll return it we don't know what
his intent was yeah or just almost lawn
and then by the time you you know you
get enough money
you won't have to worry about a shitty
lawn for a while who gets inspired to
steal a lawnmower in the middle of the
night
out of all things there was a bicycle in
there there was a lot of things he could
have just grabbed crackheads man that's
about it
where is this at i like the idea that
it's like you got to test out the
product before it was in texas he's like
this is a good llama i like the idea
he's stolen a bunch of lawn mowers and
it didn't work and he's like nah [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
because you put the gas in it himself
starts it takes did he bring his own gas
no that's the gas that was on the
property i would be less mad
right if what because he mowed the lawn
already this is why you get your
neighbors to like watch your ship i
would feel less threatened because he's
clearly not the worst criminal that's
what i'm saying like i'm like less
there's something so he's just like an
off dude he's not like a career like you
know like a mastermind he's not like
your guy who took a [ __ ] in the kid's
bathroom yeah that's yeah he was ted
bundy dude you know what i mean for sure
that was so [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that too
i didn't think that uh before i even
told you guys why i brought that up i
would hear something way worse than this
guy
you know what's funny is like people
when i told that story
everyone's like response i'm surprised
no one else said it here but we're all
adults but people would always be like
they couldn't get dna evidence from the
[ __ ] oh and i was like wow i don't think
that's how that works i also think we've
heard enough news to know that that's
not the way people don't even give a
[ __ ] yeah
they all have dna and then they're like
i guess it's a cold case
so when when the cops finally came to
like survey the house did they actually
show up the cops yeah but they were very
like yeah well and you left it unflushed
yeah did you show it to them yeah i held
i was like officer what do i do with all
this here's what we should do we ate
some of it
i have a i have a theory maybe
maybe try this if anything ever happens
to you god forbid you get robbed or
something when the cops show up
you see
[Laughter]
on the down though but i'm kind of a
senator's son
oh [ __ ] so uh if we can just keep that
between my dad is gas cone
who could speed this up i think it only
works for white people well i'm gonna
try and i'll let you guys know i just i
just like imagining nick like walking
out of his room when the cops talk his
parents and he's like don't worry i
think we got these guys
come here take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you